you should but I think whether them
legalize they're not it not stopping
anyone you know I'm saying you know I
mean it's it's it's a plant but I think
what's most important and even pot is
hemp why because but yeah people smoke
you know marijuana whatever but hemp can
see if the planet
I'm gonna top what smoking it now I
talked about him can see of the world
you know another by a bit say God give
us these herbs that almost use these
plants this is the this is the this is a
gift that we are neglecting to use so in
my in my in my mind the marijuana
struggle marijuana struggle the pod
strong is good but the hemp struggle
that is what is going to see the planet
you know cut this plant can do
everything we needed for the few will
close you know and it helped the sila
day
it regenerates the side that mean when
you plant when you plant him and you
take out that crop when you're put in
the corn are the peas are the potato it
it flourishes even more so I think there
needs to be something going on about him
to not just the smoking of this plant
the smoking for me the smoking is a is a
it's a very spiritual sacramental
private thing but if I talk about faith
the whole earth let up what using the
hemp plant to do all of these things
that it can do and I don't see why
that's a problem for governments to to
legalize the hemp plant itself you know
me I said so
everything about that you know don't get
don't let the marijuana side of it hide
it the bigger side of it you know me sit
here so keep you know if I keep that in
mind you know